vous avez tous vu cette image dans
Avengers head game niidav lire le
royaume des Nains une forge géante
alimentée par la puissance d'une étoile
comment est-ce possible grâce à la méga
structure d'anneau qui l'entoure ils
vont collecter l'énergie émise pour la
transmettre au fourneau on appelle ça
une sphère de Dzon depuis 1945 de
nombreux scientifiques cherchent une
solution pour faire de même collecter
toute l'énergie d'un soleil permettrait
un accès illimité à une source d'énergie
propre ça ouvrirait de nouvelles
opportunités comme la conquête et la
colonisation de notre système solaire
sauf qu'il faut au minimum 170 trillions
de tonnes de minerais pour la fabriquer
presque la masse de mercure ça vous
donne une idée de la puissance du grand
méchant de Full Métal alchimiste qui
t'en Pope un dans le creux de sa main
vous vous en doutez nous ne sommes pas
assez avancés pour y parvenir mais la
Chine a tenté encore plus fou créer un
soleil directement sur terre si c'est
impossible d'utiliser sa puissance dans
l'espace autant le ramener chez nous et
c'est une sacrée réussite pendant 17
minutes leur soleil artificiel a atteint
70 millions de degrés celus C fois plus
chaud qu'au centre de notre étoile
comment ont-ils fait est-ce vraiment
safe d'avoir ça sur notre planète est-ce
que vous aussi vous pouvez créer le
vôtre il y a une façon de tenter cette
expérience de façon ludique et sans
aucun risque pour notre planète comment
en plongeant dans honcasta rail pour
ceux qui ont toujours rêvé de naviguer
dans l'espace le moment est venu avec
ononcasta rail le dernier rpgsf gratuit
deovers disponible sur PC mobile et
désormais sur ps5 vous n'avez pas besoin
d'attendre la technologie du futur un
monde semi-ouvert la liberté d'explorer
différentes planètes et de recruter plus
de 30 personnag jouable en seulement 6
mois le jeu a atteint les 80 millions de
téléchargements la mise à jour 1.5
introduit un nouveau héros exclusif yyo
une FIP heureuse et introvertie avec une
queue dotée de conscience un pilier de
soutien 5 étoiles qui va devenir
essentiel à votre quête disponible à
partir du 15 novembre ensemble avec Win
fen et le reste de votre équipage partez
en mission pour capturer les fantômes et
tentz d'obtenir Ania le dernier héros 4
étoiles ajouté à cette mise à jour ce
n'est pas tout avec de nouvelles zones à
explorer des modes de jeu inédit et et
des récompenses alléchantes on castaril
vous offre une expérience cosmique
complète utilisez notre code pour
obtenir 50 Jats stellair connectez-vous
pendant 7 jours consécutifs pour avoir
un max de cadeaux et la chance de
débloquer un personnage extrêmement rare
n'attendez plus cliquez sur le lien en
description télécharger en cast rail
partez à la conquête de l'espace les
dangers d'un soleil sur Terre en avoir
un dans la nature sur notre planète est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une très
mauvaise idée déjà il est beaucoup trop
chaud seulement 5500° celus à sa surface
mais son atosphère dépasse les 2
millions de degrés tous les océans
s'évaporeraient et toutes les formes de
vie brûleraient ne laissant qu'un gros
caillou stérile flottant dans l'espace
ensuite l'attraction dépend de la masse
d'un objet le soleil est tellement gros
que sa gravité est 28 fois supérieure à
celle de la Terre toute la matière sur
notre planète serait aussi attiré par
lui ça finirait par ressembler à l'astre
divin de pain sa force serait suffisante
pour dévier les astéroïdes jusqu'à nous
et si nous sommes encore vivants c'est
la lune qui finirait par s'écraser elle
est beaucoup trop proche pour résister à
son attraction rassurez-vous ça
n'arrivera pas il est impossible de
fabriquer un deuxième soleil aussi gros
que le premier à lui tout seul il
représente 99,8 % de la matière de notre
système solaire on pourrait faire tenir
tous les autres planètes 600 fois à
l'intérieur celui créé par la Chine ne
dépasse pas les 2 m avoir un soleil
aussi petit pas de souci de gravité s'il
possède la même densité que le noyau
solaire il pèserait environ 150 tonnes
c'est beaucoup mais pas suffisant pour
attirer à lui les objets qu' l'entourent
pas de plus de météorite prévu pour les
jours à venir vous pouvez sortir
tranquille en plus de ça il est maintenu
dans un réacteur spécifique assurant sa
stabilité le noyau solaire dégage
tellement d'énergie qu'il a besoin
d'être comprimé pour éviter que cette
énergie s'échappe on parle d'une
pression de plusieurs millions de fois
supérieure à celle qu'exerce notre
atmosphère à l'air libre il ne pourrait
pas conserver sa forme sans cette force
pour le maintenir l'énergie du noyau
repousserait l'air environnante et il
commencerait à grossir pour les
personnes étant assez loin cela ferait
comme un deuxième soleil qui se lève
dans le ciel devenant de plus en plus
gros jusqu'à exploser en libérant une
puissance de 4000 matonn 30 3333 fois la
bombe d'Hiroshima une aussi grosse
explosion raserait et brûlerait tout sur
un rayon de 300 km si elle avait lu à
Paris Bruxelles et Londres seraient
réduit en cemre le souffle va faire
plusieurs fois le tour de la terre
soulevant tellement de poussière et de
terre que les rayons du soleil seraient
bloqué pendant une dizaine d'années nous
plongeant dans une air glaciaire pouvant
causer la fin de l'humanité heureusement
ce n'est pas vraiment un soleil et oui
on vous a fait marcher ce soleil
artificiel existe bien mais il n'a rien
à voir avec la petite boule lumineuse
qu'on pourrait imaginer en réalité il
s'agit d'un plasma maintenu dans un
habitacle le temps de l'expérience c'est
sa température plus chaude que le soleil
qui lui vaut son surnom mais ils n'ont
pas fait ça juste pour s'amuser il
cherche à s'approcher des conditions
présentes sur le soleil pour apprendre à
générer la même énergie que lui comment
le soleil produit de l'énergie l'homme
est déjà capable d'exploiter l'énergie
solaire grâce au panneaux photovoltaïqu
mais ce n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
comparée à tout ce qu'il aimait une fois
envoyé dans l'espace une petite partie
finit par nous atteindre mais elle doit
encore traverser l'atmosphère qui va en
absorber 23 % et en réfléchir 20 9 %
vers l'espace au final c'est moins de la
moitié de ce qui atint d'autre planète
qui parvient jusqu'au sol un vrai gachi
car si on parvenait à collecter toute
cette énergie on pourrait couvrir les
besoins énergétiques de toute notre
planète si on veut l'exploiter
complètement il faut la reproduire et
donc comprendre comment elle est créée
mais est-ce que vous savez vraiment ce
qui est le soleil moi je pensais que
c'était des bulles de gaz qui brûlaient
à des billions de kilomètres de nous
vous avez déjà entendu ça et B c'est
faux le soleil n'est pas en feu et c'est
pas une bulle de gaz enfin pas tout à
fait la matière qui le constitue est
tellement chaude qu'elle n'est plus
gazeuse elle atteint alors un état dans
lequel les électrons ont suffisamment
d'énergie pour se séparer de leur atome
les deux se déplacee librement dans la
matière c'est ce qu'on appelle du plasma
vous en avez déjà vu car le plasma peut
être obtenu à partir de n'importe quel
gaz sur Terre on peut l'obseré sous
forme d'Auror Boréal et de foudre mais
également dans nos télés et nos néons il
s'agit simplement d'un tube dans lequel
le gaz est transformé en plasma par un
arc électrique c'est seulement sous cet
état que l'énergie solaire peut être
produite mais ça ne fonctionne pas avec
n'importe quel gaz il va nous falloir
trouver ou le bon comment en étudiant la
lumière qu'il éimet la lumière blanche
est constituée de toutes les couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel si on étudie celle émise
par le soleil on observe cela vous le
voyez certaines zones sont noires c'est
parce qu'une partie de la lumière a été
absorbée ce sont les éléments présents
sur son trajet qui sont responsables
quand elle va passer au travers ils vont
en absorber une partie en trouvant
l'élément correspondant à chaque espace
noir on peut déterminer lequel constitue
notre Soleil et deux éléments sort du
l'eau 92 % d'hydrogène et 7,8 % d'hélium
les 0,2 % restants sont constitués de
composants plus lourds comme le carbone
le fer ou l'azote mais attention ces 0,2
petits pour qui semblent insignifiants
représente plus de 600 fois le poids de
la terre c'est bon j'ai des bonbonnes
d'hydrogène et d'hélium je fais quoi
avec ça maintenant c'est là où les
choses se corsent on ne peut pas juste
mélanger les gaz et les chauffer il faut
également que toutes les conditions
soient réunies pour que le soleil nous
révèle son arme secrète l'hydrogène
présente au cœur du soleil est à l'état
de plasma débarrassé de son électron il
est réduit à un simple proton flottant
dans la matière enfin flottant pas
vraiment il reçoit tellement d'énergie
avec la chaleur et la pression qu'il
fonce à toute vitesse jusqu'au moment où
il va percuter un autre proton qui sont
charger tous les deux positivement ils
vont se repousser comme deux aant si on
met leur pôle sud face à face mais
parfois la magie opère au moment de la
collision un proton va libérer de
l'énergie lui permettant de devenir un
neutron en se transformant il va perdre
sa charge positive il faut plusieurs
milliers d'années pour que cela se
produise on appelle ce phénomène la
radioactivité betta sans ça impossible
de fusionner les protons rien ne se
serait possible et notre étoile n'aurait
jamais vu le jour ainsi le proton et le
neutron vont se percuter tellement
violemment qu'ils vont fusionner formant
un nouveau noyau et libérant de
l'énergie c'est là que réside la
puissance de l'énergie solaire la fusion
nucléaire et c'est ce quiessaie de
reproduire les scientifiques des
installations comme le collisionneur de
particules du cerne permett d'étudier
l'impact entre deux particules l'atome
obtenu possède un seul proton il s'agit
donc toujours d'hydrogène par contre il
est devenu plus lourd à cause du poids
du neutron en plus on appelle ça un
isotope celui-ci s'appelle du du
deterium un atome stable qu'on peut
trouver dans la nature et même dans
l'eau qu' bois il va à son tour être
percuté par un proton avec lequel il va
fusionner libérant une seconde vague
d'énergie ça prend quelques secondes vu
la quantité phénoménale d'hydrogène
présente en fusionnant on obtient un
atome contenant deux protons ce n donc
plus de l'hydrogène mais de l'hélium
deux atomes d'hélium vont ensuite se
heter et fusionner pour créer un isotope
de l'hélium il faudrait quelques
centaines d'années pour que la dernière
étape puisse avoir lieu lors de la
fusion deux protons sont libérés et vont
pouvoir participer à une nouvelle
réaction de fus perpétrant ainsi le
cycle à elle seu la dernière étape de
fusion génère 17,6 méga électronvt si on
compare à une centrale nucléaire la
fission d'un seul atome d'uranium 235 en
produit 200 loin d'être aussi efficace
au contraire un atome d'hélium est
presque 60 fois plus petit qu'un atome
d'uranium à quantité de matière égale la
fusion de l'hydrogène créerait 5 fois
plus d'énergie au cœur du soleil ce sont
environ 600 millions de tonnes
d'hydrogène qui fusionn pour créer 596
millions de tonnes d'hélium chaque
seconde libérant l'équivalent de 4
millions de tonnes d'énergie à quoi ça
correspond c'est comme si 18illard820
millions de tarbomb explosaient chaque
seconde c'est le défi que ce sont lancés
les scientifiques parvenir à comprendre
et maîtriser la fusion nucléaire à temps
pour sauver notre futur de la crise
écologique peut-on réaliser une fusion
nucléaire oui j'espère que vous avez
apprécié notre vidéo n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner je rigole mais c'est vrai
on sait le faire le problème c'est que
la fusion obtenue génère moins d'énergie
que ce qu'on lui a fourni ce n'est pas
rentable dans les années 70 un projet
européen est créé pour comprendre et
maîtriser la fusion nucléaire le projet
jet en 1983 il réussit à créer un plasma
chauffé à 100 millions de degrés mais à
l'époque il ne pouvait le maintenir que
quelques secondes le soleil chinois
n'est pas le premier simplement celui
qui a duré le plus longtemps en 1997 le
projet réalise même une fusion nucléaire
qui a duré 5 secondes le problème c'est
qu'elle ne libère que 75 % de l'énergie
nécessaire pour la mettre en place pour
y parvenir ils ont chauffé des isotopes
d'hydrogène dans une chambre à vide en
forme de donuts avec des micro-ondes
rien à voir avec celui de ta cuisine
cela va permettre d'obtenir le temps
désiré plasma sauf qu'à de telle
température l'appareil devrait fondre
c'est là que la deuxième étape rentre en
jeu il va falloir confiner le plasma
pour qu'il ne touche pas les parois du
réacteur le plasma est constitué
d'électrons et de protons il a donc une
charge électrique on pourra donc le
repousser grâce au champ
électromagnétique en entourant
l'extérieur des parois avec une bobine
électrique on pourra s'assurer que le
plasma ne s'approchera pas des bord
aucun risque de faire fondre le réacteur
c'est une technologie de fusion par
confinement magnétique on retrouve deux
type de réacteur de ce type les
stéérator et les tokamac à ce jour le
projet a permis la réalisation de plus
de 100000 plasmas et fusion un travail
ayant permis à d'autres équipes à
travers le monde de progresser encore
plus loin mais les choses ont changé
est-ce que vous vous souvenez de ce que
vous étiez en train de faire le 13
décembre 2022 sûrement en train de
préparer Noël et de courir acheter vos
derniers cadeaux pendant ce temps une
équipe californienne est parvenue à
créer une fusion nucléaire générant plus
d'énergie qu'elle en consomme la toute
première dans l'histoire de l'humanité
pour ça ils se sont servis d'un laser
mais pas n'importe lequel ils ont
utilisé et le NIF le plus gros laser du
monde l'installation fait la taille de
trois terrains de foot et a coûté 3,5
milliards de dollars entièrement designé
pour réussir une fusion nucléaire ils
ont séparé le laser initial en 192
rayons qui vont être chargés en énergie
jusqu'à atteindre la puissance voulue
une fois remontés à bloc ils vont être
dirigés vers un système optique
convertissant les lasers infrarouges en
UV de là ils seront tirés sur une cible
de 5 mm il faut être précis un petit
cylindre en or dans lequel se trouve une
capsule pas plus grande qu'un grain de
po Avre elle contient un gaz de deterium
et de tritium deux isotopes de
l'hydrogène la moitié des lasers va
pénétrer le cylindre par le haut et
l'autre moitié par le bas en frappant
les parois intérieures de l'OL r l'or va
absorber l'énergie des lasers et va en
restituer une partie sous forme de rayon
X qui vont bombarder la capsule elle va
chauffer en une fraction de seconde une
chauffe tellement rapide et puissante
que l'extérieur va se dilater et le gaz
à l'intérieur va se comprimer la
compression va avoir lieu à plus de 300
km/s entraînant une pression de 100 MB
on obtient ainsi des les conditions de
pression et de température proche du
Soleil ce qui permet de déclencher une
fusion nucléaire ils ont pu obtenir 1,5
fois plus d'énergie que ce qu'ils ont
utilisé ils ont même réitéré leur
exploit en juillet en obtenant encore
plus d'énergie que la fois précédente on
appelle cette méthode la fusion par
confinement plus de 250 réacteurs à
fusion nucléaire existe à travers le
monde c'est grâce à tous ces travaux
préliminaires que le projet chinois East
est parvenu à maintenir un plasma à une
température de 70 millions de degrés
durant 17 minutes détrenant ainsi le
précédent record de 6 minutes 30 détenu
par la France ils travaillent tous dans
un seul but faire avancer la technologie
pour mener à bien un projet encore plus
ambitieux itther il a vu le jour en 1985
et a pour but la conception de la plus
grande installation de fusion nucléaire
au monde 35 pays font partie de
l'aventure et fournissent le matériel et
les connaissances nécessaires à sa
construction depuis 2005 la construction
a commencé dans la commune de cadarche
près d'exen Provence et en 2020 le
montage du réactur a pu débuter comme
elle n'est pas encore opérationnelle
l'installation ouvre même ses portes au
public une occasion unique de voir à
l'intérieur ou dans quelques années
peut-être nous parviendrons à produire
une fusion nucléaire alimentant nos
télés et nos frigos l'avancée de tel
projet est très suivi à travers le monde
on l'a dit beaucoup les voient comme la
solution à la crise énergétique que
subit l'humanité malgré ça les
spécialistes rest sceptiques rien ne
prouve que nous parviendrons à maîtriser
cette technologie peut-être que cette
solution arrive trop tard pour empêcher
les dommages déjà créés pourtant si
l'homme parvient à la maîtriser c'est un
nouveau monde qui s'enfre à lui une
énergie propre et illimité la
possibilité de générer depuis un verre
d'eau autant d'énergie que depuis un
baril de pétrole en plus de ça pas
d'emballement possible si le réacteur se
brise le plasma refroidit et tout
s'arrête encore merci onc pour leur
soutien télécharger le jeu en
description sans oublier notre code pour
faire le plein de cadeau qui sait de
nouvelles technologies pourrait voir le
jour permettant la construction de
réacteur à fusion au cœur de navette
repoussant ainsi plus loin les limites
que l'homme est capable
[Musique]
d'atteindre